all right airline passengers weren't
just losing their clothes Kevin yeah
they was also losing their damn Minds
take a look you neither Believe it or
they cannot believe it I don't give two
but I am telling you right now
that back there is not real
what do you think other white women
think to themselves when they see that I
feel like it's a heavy burden for them I
do I think I just want to know what the
reaction is like like you know there's
times where we see like black people do
something like godamn you know what I
mean us right like we did it again
right in that case what do you think the
white women say like are they upset like
I think they just go shopping like
that's okay yeah they just go shopping
everything's fine but also when did
everybody start tripping on planes like
it really did just happen it's been
recent like everybody just started
flipping out why are we so patient what
happened to the shut the ups midle
as she's talking how did she get through
that whole speech without getting hit in
the head with a soft piece of fruit like
in the middle of that speech a fruit cup
shut up
who did that I don't know here
come another one full fruit cup we
supposed to take off what happened to
the impatient passenger we supposed to
be in the air come on your damn face
yeah I bet you with a soft Peach right
in the back of your head
lady